We are willing to do the hard things to overcome the many challenges.
This is what brings out the best in us.
We are go for a mission to the moon.
Our path has led to success, and to bitter losses.
We come together today to mourn the loss of seven brave Americans.
Yet, even when faced with tragedy and setbacks, we persevere.
We keep striving.
We keep believing.
From space, we see our planet as a whole.
We see the challenges facing it...
...and we face those challenges, together.
We will not give up.
We challenge convention.
We refuse to accept the status quo.
The time at hand is hard.
But we will persevere.
We can still draw hope from the moon and the stars.
From space.
From exploration.
There is a new day beyond the challenges we face now.